[Applause]
it was an event the queen was personally
involved in planning
on monday we'll see the full spectacle
of her state funeral play out in central
london
rehearsals already taking place timing
everything to precision
at 10 35 on monday morning the bearer
party will begin to move the queen's
coffin from westminster hall to the gun
carriage the king the queen's children
and grandchildren will all walk behind
in a procession to westminster abbey at
11am the funeral service will begin
11 55 the funeral will end with a
two-minute silence
at 12 15 the procession will leave the
abbey making its way through central
london and then at one o'clock the
coffin will be moved from the gun
carriage to the state hearse and driven
to windsor castle
four o'clock in the afternoon the
committal service will be held in saint
george's chapel before at 7 30 in the
evening a private service will take
place where the queen will be buried
alongside the duke of edinburgh in the
king george vi chapel
i think this is bigger than george at
the six bigger than george the first
bigger than victoria so i wait to be
convinced that there will ever have been
a bigger
event and truly
the biggest collection of world leaders
in the 21st century
among the military pageantry the
personal the king and his siblings will
again stage a vigil by her coffin on
friday night this time at westminster
hall
and her grandchildren will join them to
walk in the funeral procession
the queen's own piper will play the
lament at windsor as just like her
husband prince philip this time her
coffin will be lowered into the vault
before privately being buried beside him
for so many decades it was the queen and
prince philip who would welcome
dignitaries to this part of london for
any big events of course this time it's
down to the queen's children and
grandchildren you get the sense also
really want to make sure that everything
we're going to see here on monday also
feels open to everyone and that's why
you'll see representatives from the nhs
in the procession and members of the
queen's charities in the congregation
[Music]
we know they have been comforted by the
public reaction the queen's
daughter-in-law the council of wessex
saying thank you along with her husband
prince edward in manchester
their help now is invaluable to the new
king who having signed off the funeral
plans now has more duties ahead
including a state event at buckingham
palace on sunday hosting all of the
world leaders just 24 hours before he
says his own final farewell to his
beloved mother
rhiannon mills sky news in central
london